bonjour à toutes et à tous figurez vous
que nous avons une petite nouvelle à
vous annoncer
vous avez été nombreux à nous demander
des vidéos plus longue avec des
thématiques plus large
comment mesurer l'univers dans quelques
semaines
votre chaîne s de sciences zds pour les
intimes va s'élargir s'enrichir rassurez
vous je ne vais nulle part on continue
toujours les épisodes us de science que
vous connaissez mais on prépare de
nouvelles séries qui vont aborder la
science au sens large et toujours avec
un ton un peu décalé désolé c'est devenu
un peu notre marque de fabrique
bref nous avons donc recruter de
nouvelles têtes pour présenter ces
épisodes
et pas n'importe lesquels chance d'un
oui et moi c'est rené descartes la
chaîne zdf a évolué
oui bon allez garde
voilà vous êtes dans mon studio on a
calé chez toi beney c'est super ta
chambre
par contre
c'est normal que j'arrive pas à ton et
20 têtes là oui c'est ça la vie en deux
dimensions
ok super bon et est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un peu le principe de 7,6
alors on parle d'une problématique
plutôt vaste cinq minutes obligé de
mouiller
est ce que le temps pour vraiment faire
des brousses humeur et puis on discute
on devrait avec ses collègues
scientifiques
il va y avoir différentes questions déjà
il va y avoir essayé de comprendre un
peu comment est structuré un gros animal
donc des épisodes plus long
présenté par vous deux pas uniquement il
y aura aussi marie et leonardo au ils
sont en train de travailler web et j'en
profite aussi pour vous dire qu'on peut
sera également d'autres séries décalé
sur la chaîne des sciences dans une
galaxie lointaine très lointaine
mais côté scientifique le fond restera
toujours aussi sérieux
percutant comme chute